this video is brought to you by
brilliant.org
hi welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
it seems that at the start of this
decade the 2020s the electric car
industry is leaving behind the niche of
tech enthusiasts and environmentalists
and shifting into the mainstream common
brands like ford hyundai kia and volvo
having their own ev models signifies
this as a clear signal
and boy has this been interesting for me
to watch happen i remember back in 2011
whenever i would make early cold fusion
videos about tesla people would laugh
there would be comments saying electric
cars would never work evs had been tried
many times before
leaving tesla completely aside for now
there's no arguing it is true that
electric cars have a simpler power plant
and transmission require less
maintenance have instant torque and
generally perform better than their
petrol counterparts
that being said there's still room for
improvement
ev battery technology remains as one of
the last hurdles it still causes
hesitation for would-be buyers
we've covered some research progress
before but what you're about to see
today is interesting because it's been
proven to work in a vehicle with
impressive results
imagine driving over 1 200 kilometers or
750 miles on a single charge by swapping
out a standard battery in a tesla model
s with a new experimental one
in this episode we'll take a deeper look
you are watching
tv
the fledgling ev industry collectively
has come up with a contemporary solution
to range anxiety and they're simply
called charging networks they're all
over the us and are popping up in parts
of europe and other nations around the
world the aim is to make sure that
you've always got the option to charge
when you're in a pinch
the only thing is there's often problems
sometimes the charging stations break
there can also be waiting times and
different cars can unfortunately use
different networks altogether it's
obvious that better batteries are a
great solution to a lot of these
problems but how can we do this
an interesting method for solving this
battery problem was thought up by the
michigan based startup our next energy
or one inc
their method was to split the battery
into two
they call this dual battery system
gemini
for a visual representation take a look
at this chart
on the y-axis is statistically how much
the average driver would travel a given
distance daily
distances are shown on the x-axis
the overall chart describes the gemini
battery system
let's start with the left-hand side of
the chart
depicted in blue is a low-cost but
robust lithium-ion phosphate battery
its job is to do the daily drives and
the heavy lifting under 150 miles or 241
kilometers
on the right hand side there's a
secondary high energy density battery
this battery technology can extend the
range up to 750 miles or 1200 kilometers
the exact details of what goes on in
this battery are scarce we just know its
proprietary
that normally could raise some red flags
but we'll discuss some issues of trust
later in the episode
the thinking of the battery system goes
something like this most people rarely
do more than 60 miles or 100 kilometers
of daily driving so a regular battery
can handle that
but when those rare times come and
there's a need to do greater distances
the second battery can take over
since there isn't much info on the
propriety battery technology i would
have to assume that a drawback of such
long range would have to be the
stability of the chemistry that is while
the battery may have a high capacity it
may not have as good a long-term battery
life in other words if you keep
recharging and discharging it too often
it will degrade but in this use case
that's okay because it's not going to be
used remotely as often as the workhorse
short-range battery
this experimental battery was swapped
into a tesla model s it takes the same
amount of space as the standard pack but
it contains twice the energy that is 203
kilowatt hours versus 103.9 kilowatt
hours that's massive
the energy density definitely showed its
effectiveness
traveling at an average speed of 55
miles per hour or 88 kilometers an hour
the car clocked in over 752 miles or
1200 kilometers without the need to
recharge
it traveled so far that even
accompanying cars had to stop for fuel
to fill up
[Music]
the results were validated by a third
party using a vehicle dynometer
another test under controlled conditions
indoors rated the battery pack at even
higher
882 miles or
1419 kilometers and this was at the same
speed
so we have to put this into context just
to see how remarkable this is to give
you an idea 1 400 kilometers of range on
a single tank would put this car as one
of the longest driving cars of any kind
that you can buy
the website
drive.com.iu did extensive testing of
over 400 petrol and diesel cars
the average range was about 780
kilometers or 484 miles
in fact there was only one car that did
better than this experimental battery a
diesel toyota land cruiser and that has
a massive fuel tank
this is very interesting
okay so now we get to the questions
who is this one company and how did they
come from nowhere and do all of this is
this a big scam
well a good place to start would be with
credibility
one's founder mujeeb ijaz has a colorful
career according to his linkedin resume
he was heavily involved in the first
production and applications of iron
phosphate based lithium-ion batteries
for automative use the battery powered
the winning car the porsche 919 hybrid
in the 24-hour le moore race
his previous company a123 automotive
produced battery systems for fiskar
company and for chevrolet spark ev
in 2014 he then went on to work as a
senior director in apple working on
energy storage he would quit in 2020 and
then founded one
in total he's got 30 years of being a
battery systems engineer so to me it
seems like he would be someone who would
fit the bill
so this demonstration is truly
groundbreaking if all is as it seems but
just because of the state of everything
these days it also must be taken with a
grain of salt there's going to be a few
questions that need to be asked if you
drive aggressively does the battery's
range advantage fall off rapidly what
about city driving how long will the
battery keep charge over repeated charge
and discharge cycles what about the cost
fortunately we'll know more next year
when one will demonstrate a presentation
of the prototype gemini battery system
but as it stands for now driving on a
single charge for 1 200 kilometers or
760 miles or even 1 400 kilometers and
882 miles on a single charge in ideal
conditions just opens up the door for
the next chapter in evs in general i
generally and genuinely think this is
awesome and definitely something to keep
your eye on if this company does indeed
accomplish this by putting it into
production this is only a great thing
for all of us as consumers so more power
to them
if you find technology inspirational and
you want to understand more learning how
things work can be rewarding both in a
personal and professional sense
brilliant is the best way to learn stem
subjects in a fun and engaging way they
have courses on cryptographics machine
learning physics chemistry and more it's
a great foundation to get a handle on
our rapidly evolving world
today if you visit brilliant.org cold
fusion you can start learning stem for
free and the first 200 people will get
20 percent off their annual premium
subscription
okay so that's about it for me
my name is digogo and you've been
watching cold fusion
if you do want to discuss this topic
more in depth head on over to the cold
fusion discord i'm a bit more active on
there these days
also on the cold fusion discord we have
an area for video suggestions so if you
want to see a new video topic go ahead
and suggest it there but you should keep
in mind that it has to appeal to a broad
audience to ensure this other members of
the discord can write your suggestions
so thanks for watching and i'll see you
again soon for the next episode
cheers guys
have a good one
is
[Music]
it's me thinking